.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Diese Küsserei,
die wir in der Schweiz haben,
gibt es hier nicht.
Ich will sie immer küssen.
* Lachen *
Hier in Kanada
interessiert es niemanden,
ob Ehemann und Ehemann,
Ehefrau und Ehemann ...
Das ist, als würde man sagen:
"Es hat heute Wolken am Himmel."
Er nahm mich mal
zu einer Zeremonie mit,
obwohl ich damals noch keine Hindu
war und keine Ahnung habe.
So als wären wir
schon längere Zeit zusammen.
Man hat diese Vision:
"Ich bin dann in Schweden im Wald
und
wir bauen etwas an diesem Haus rum."
Die Realität
ist natürlich ganz anders.
* Romantische Ballade *
Zwei Länder eine Liebe -
das ist "Hin und weg".
Die sechsjährige Mayari
hat guten Grund,
sich die Augen zu reiben.
Denn vor zwei Wochen
lebte sie mit Schwester Zara
und den Eltern
noch im winterlichen St. Gallen.
Vater Didi Kunz ist frühpensioniert.
Nach eineinhalb Jahren in der Schweiz
zog es ihn mit den Kindern und Frau
Melisa zurück auf die Philippinen.
Hey, langsam.
Okay.
Als wir das Tor öffneten,
war ich glücklich und aufgeregt:
"Wir sind endlich hier."
Doch drinnen sahen wir,
dass alles kaputt war,
die Pflanzen verwelkt,
alles schmutzig.
Das machte mich traurig.
Wir können ihn
im Schlafzimmer aufstellen,
dann haben wir etwas grün dort.
- We have to make ...
Hast du gehört, Schatzi?
- Schatzi, Kompost, bitte.
Didi ist 63-, Melisa 37-jährig.
Es ist alles sehr trocken.
Sie sind seit zehn Jahren ein Paar.
Am liebsten
wären die beiden Selbstversorger.
Komm her mit deinen sanften Händen,
sonst mache ich das falsch.
What can I do, Schatzi? Da?
- Ja.
I do this for you.
Wir haben jetzt ca. zwei Wochen
nur aufgeräumt und sauber gemacht.
Es ist
noch ein bisschen ein Ghetto hier.
Es dauert noch, bis wir
auf dem Level von früher sind.
Es hat viele Ameisen.
- Scheisse.
Wir müssen uns beeilen.
Ich bin 100%ig davon überzeugt,
dass es auch in der Schweiz
eine Frau gegeben hätte,
die genauso zu mir passen würde.
Aber die zu finden ...
Und ich habe sie gefunden.
Ich könnte keine Bessere haben.
Wie schwierig ist es,
einen Sechser im Lotto zu haben?
Nicht alles, Mayari.
- Nur drei.
Drei? Und dann?
- Ja.
Mayari besuchte in der Schweiz
den Kindergarten.
Die zwölfjährige Zara
ging in die Primarschule.
Sie lernte Deutsch
und hatte viele Freundinnen.
Meine Lehrerin hat mir das gegeben.
Und ich glaube,
ich werde es da hinstellen.
365 Tage Glück.
Ja.
Das ist mein Zimmer.
Und es gibt Chaos.
Noch muss sich Zara
an die Umstellung gewöhnen.
In St. Gallen ist alles betoniert,
aus Zement.
Hier ist vieles aus Bambus und Holz.
Auch das Bett ist aus Bambus.
Es ist nicht aus Metall oder so.
Ich hoffe,
ich kann einen Tisch finden,
und auch ein Moskitonetz.
Es kommen jeden Abend Moskitos.
Die beissen dich in den Fuss.
Da musst du
deinen ganzen Körper beschützen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Tambobo Bay
gehört zum kleinen Dorf Bonbonon.
Bis zum Hafen sind es nur 500 m.
Die meisten Menschen
leben von der Fischerei.
Dieser hier ist besser.
Ist der zu gross? No?
Ich weiss nicht so recht.
I don't know.
- Für mich ist er zu gross.
Das Feilschen überlässt Didi Melisa,
denn die Einheimischen
sprechen Visaya.
Der ist perfekt.
- (Mann) 1'306.
* Sie sprechen Visaya. *
Sie haben schon gesehen,
dass ich Ausländer bin.
Ich glaube, im Moment
sind wir bei 1'000 Pesos.
Das sind rund 20 Fr.
Im Normalfall
kostet der vielleicht 10-12 Fr.
Gekauft ist gekauft.
Das ist schon gut.
Ich will keine Fische essen.
Wieso?
Du hast doch immer Fisch gegessen.
Ja.
Die Augen ...
- Hey.
Hey.
Halte ihn hier und hier.
Perfekt.
Er ist schwer.
- Nicht fallen lassen.
Schau mal.
* Lachen *
Zumachen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Mayari, kannst du noch mehr bringen?
There, on the side.
Das ist für unser Mittagessen.
Okay? Ja?
- Ja.
Du musst auf das Feuer aufpassen.
Pass auf.
Mama Melisa ist in einfachen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.
Ihre Werte
will sie den Kindern weitergeben.
Das ist mühsam.
Normalerweise
machen wir das in der Küche.
Das Problem ist: Wir haben drinnen
keine Wasserleitung,
darum
machen wir es hier bei der Pumpe.
Hier ist es einfacher.
Seit seiner Frühpensionierung
hat Didi alle Zeit der Welt.
Auch die Kinder, die
noch nicht zur Schule gehen müssen,
geniessen die neue Freiheit.
Wer kommt denn da?
(Zara) Die Füllung ist lecker.
Sieht gut aus.
- Guten Appetit.- Guten Appetit.
Mmh.
Hast du davon probiert?
Es ist gut, oder? Poppa?- Ja.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
- Nein.
Fisch gehört zum Leben
auf den Philippinen.
Die Kinder sollen wissen,
woher er kommt
und welchen sie essen können.
Ich möchte, dass sie dasselbe essen
wie alle Menschen hier.
Sie sollen lernen,
mit dem Leben hier zurechtzukommen.
Ich weiss wirklich nicht mehr,
wann wir das erste Mal
darüber gesprochen haben.
Ich glaube Romain sofort,
dass ich sagte,
dass ich gerne ein Kind möchte.
Ich sagte: "Ich nicht unbedingt.
Ich bin auch ohne glücklich."
"Aber ja, warum nicht?"
Von da an reifte dieser Gedanke
in unseren Köpfen
und das hat auch dazu geführt,
dass wir geheiratet haben.
Denn
wenn man als Familie zusammenlebt,
bildet die Ehe einen guten Rahmen.
Gestern reisten Jamal Othman
und Romain Haguenauer
Hals über Kopf
von Montreal nach Hamilton.
Ihr Baby ist unterwegs -
Leihmutter Ashley liegt in den Wehen,
zehn Tage zu früh.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir heute viel schlafen werden.
Gestern ging alles so schnell.
Wir mussten unverhofft
alles schnell zusammenpacken.
Wir sind zu Hause
noch nicht ganz bereit.
Gestern war ich etwas gestresst
und dachte:
"Das kann jetzt nicht so ablaufen."
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
wir würden die Geburt verpassen.
Jetzt bin ich froh:
Wir waren eine Nacht im Hotel
und jetzt gehen wir ins Spital.
1 Std.
- Jetzt?
"Ich bekomme jetzt die Narkose -
1 Std."
One hour.
- Okay.
Wir müssen gehen.
Jetzt weiss ich:
In 1 Std. sind wir zu dritt.
Es geht mir gut.
Ich bin glücklich,
aufgeregt, etwas aufgewühlt.
Aber ich habe es im Griff.
- Gehen wir.
Der Weg zum Leihmutterbaby
dauerte vier lange Jahre.
Jetzt geht alles ganz schnell.
Das ist die Wickeltasche,
die ich von einem meiner Brüder
erhalten habe.
Das Tuch ...
Ich wollte auf Youtube schauen,
wie man
das Tuch mit dem Baby anzieht.
Das konnte ich alles nicht mehr.
Ein paar Trainerhosen ...
Wir wussten nicht,
wie lange wir bleiben,
und haben innerhalb von 30 Min.
alles reingeworfen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Heute beginnt für die beiden
ein neues Leben.
Vorgestern
waren wir noch gross im Ausgang.
Der letzte mit unseren Freunden.
Und jetzt gehen wir rein
und in ca. 30 Min.
kommt das Kind auf die Welt
und dann direkt in unsere Arme.
Es war immer schon mein Traum,
so zu leben.
Und dann hat man es
und man hat eine Krise.
Wieso? Was läuft da falsch?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, die Menschen sind nie zufrieden.
Es ist eine Herausforderung,
diese Frage zu beantworten.
Wieso ist man nicht glücklich?
Du bist nicht glücklich?
Dieses Haus hat Niklas
für seine grosse Liebe gebaut.
Vor eineinhalb Jahren zog Florence
zu ihm nach Südschweden -
mit neun Hunden im Gepäck.
Achtung, Mädchen.
Die 51-Jährige
hat ihr Herz den Tieren verschrieben.
Dafür nimmt sie viel Arbeit auf sich.
Ich putze jeden Tag sehr viel,
aus verschiedenen Gründen:
Erstens ist es mir sonst nicht wohl,
zweitens
hat Niklas eine Hundehaarallergie.
Jeden Tag wird alles gesaugt,
auch die Kissen.
Alles wird abgesaugt. Ich
mag es gerne schön und sauber.
So viele Hunde zu haben
ist kein Widerspruch zu Sauberkeit.
So. Aufstehen.
- Zweite Runde.
Second round.
Es wird wehtun,
wenn wir es wegnehmen.- Ja.
Niklas hatte vor Kurzem eine
notfallmässige Blinddarmoperation.
Jetzt muss er sich zu Hause erholen.
Es ist okay.
Andere Menschen
haben viel Schlimmeres.
Ich bin okay.
Es ist nur etwas langweilig.
Ich laufe rum und schaue,
ob es etwas gibt, das ich tun kann.
"Nein."
Es ist kalt.
- Frische Luft.
Gehst du da lang?
- Ja.
Doch Niklas
leidet an den Folgen der Operation.
Er ist stark eingeschränkt.
Hier sind sie.
Ich bringe eines.
- Warte, warte!
Ich trage sie.
Nein, nein, nein. Du nimmst das.
Könntest du auch die Papiere nehmen?
Sie sind etwas zu schwer für mich.
Come on.
Der 50-Jährige ist ein Macher.
Er hat das Wohnhaus, das Haus
für die Gäste und die Garage gebaut.
Normalerweise
führt er ein kleines KMU.
Like this.
Ich schneide sie zurecht,
damit sie passen.
Müssen wir sie zurechtschneiden?
Ja, jetzt machen wir es,
wie ich will.
Ich sage nichts.
- Danke.
Okay.
Du bist zu schnell.
Wir müssen sie nicht schneiden,
wir fügen sie einfach zusammen.
Wenn Niklas seine Ruhe haben will,
zieht er sich in seine Garage zurück.
It's a long way down.
Hier pflegt er sein Hobby
und vergisst die Welt um sich herum.
Ja, das ist gut.
Sonst würden wir
zu nah aufeinanderhocken.
Ich glaube,
es ist eine gute Kombination.
Hier ist mein Bier.
Hier ein Lager.
Wenn Freunde kommen, wissen sie,
dass ich immer Bier habe.
Und sie müssen mir helfen,
das zu trinken.
Florence entspannt sich
auf den täglichen Spaziergängen
mit ihren Hunden.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ja. Gleich sind wir oben.
Hm?
Pepe, komm.
Sky.
Hier findet sie Trost, wenn sie
Heimweh nach den beiden Töchtern hat,
die sie
in der Schweiz zurückgelassen hat.
Nicht zu weit, Sky. Komm.
* Pfeifen *
Und doch:
Wenn ich so etwas sehe,
ist das für mich das Schönste.
Dann habe ich das Gefühl,
alles richtig gemacht zu haben.
Sie kennt auch Tiefpunkte.
Es gab einen Moment,
in dem sie alles infrage stellte.
Niklas war am Bierbrauen.
Den gekochten Hopfen
hatte er beiseitegestellt.
Eine schlimme Geschichte.
Wir unterhielten uns und ich sah,
dass Ginger zu diesem Sack rannte,
ihn packte und aufriss.
Ich hatte ja keine Ahnung
und dachte:
"Oh nein, sie macht eine Schweinerei
mit diesem grünen Zeugs."
Dann fing sie an zu fressen.
Ich sagte: "Ginger hör auf."
Ich weiss nicht,
wie viel sie erwischte,
vielleicht eine Handvoll.
Was Niklas nicht wusste:
Hopfen kann für Hunde tödlich sein.
Ginger
zeigte Vergiftungserscheinungen.
Noch in der Nacht
brachte Florence sie nach Jönköping,
aber die Tierstation war geschlossen.
Wir hupten einfach, klopften
an jede Türe, ich schrie ...
Die diensthabende Tierärztin
nahm Ginger dann entgegen,
aber sie starb 20 Min. später.
Da dachte ich wirklich, ich würde
alles zusammenpacken und gehen.
Wenn ich meine Tiere hierherbringe
und ihnen nicht mal
eine tierärztliche Versorgung
im Notfall garantieren kann ...
Ich fühlte mich lange sehr schuldig.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wir mussten es
auf die harte Tour lernen.
Jetzt schliesse ich immer ab,
damit kein Hund reinkommt.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Das Erste, was mir einfällt,
wenn wir über Leihmütter sprechen,
ist, dass es aussergewöhnlich ist.
Es ist ein Geschenk,
um Menschen zu helfen.
Nicht nur Homosexuellen.
Auch Heterosexuelle
nehmen Leihmütter in Anspruch.
Wir hatten extremes Glück
und sind sehr dankbar dafür.
Wie die Welt funktioniert,
können wir nicht ändern.
Leihmutter Ashley
hat per Kaiserschnitt
einen Jungen auf die Welt gebracht.
Sie braucht Ruhe
und will nicht gefilmt werden.
* Das Baby weint. *
Noam Camille
heisst der neue Erdenbürger:
3'130 g, 51,7 cm.
* Ruhige Musik *
Je pense, qu'il est un petit grand.
Ein kerngesundes Baby.
* Ruhige Musik *
Er beruhigt sich sofort.
Er hat Schluckauf.
- Oui.
Vielleicht träumt er.
- Ja, er träumt.
Als wir ihn
zum ersten Mal schreien hörten
und dann sahen
und zum ersten Mal halten konnten -
das war unglaublich.
Das ist jemand Neues - unser Sohn.
Er ist hier.
Wenn man weiss, dass er gesund ist
und alles gut ist, ist das so schön.
Er hat noch kein Pipi gemacht.
À la naissance il a fait ...
Noam ist
aus einer Eizellenspende entstanden,
die
mit Jamals Samen befruchtet wurde.
Diese
wurde Leihmutter Ashley eingepflanzt.
Sie und Noam
sind genetisch nicht verwandt.
De penser que ...
Wir sind jetzt alles für ihn,
von diesem Moment an,
für viele Jahre.
Er wird viele Menschen kennenlernen,
aber im Moment sind es nur wir.
Das ist grossartig.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich bin der Erste.
Der Erstgeborene.
- Ja.
Der Erstgeborene ist wichtig
für die älteren Familienmitglieder.
Es ist wichtig,
dass der Sohn Kinder hat.
Sehr wichtig.
Sie fragten uns danach.
Aber was sollen wir tun?
Wir können keine haben.
Ja.
In Bali sind Kinder
eben die Altersversicherung.
Die kümmern sich dann um die Eltern.
Darum ist es so wichtig,
dass man Kinder hat.
Auf Bali hilft Dewa
seiner 86-jährigen Grossmutter
in deren Tempel
in ihrem Haus in Ganyar.
Nein, Bruno, wir wollen jetzt beten.
Ach du.
Als ältester Sohn hält Dewa
die Zeremonien für die Götter ab.
Unter dem strengen Blick
von Vater Aba Aji.
Es ist wichtig, die Götter
erst um Erlaubnis zu bitten.
Danach können wir tun,
was wir wollen.
Vor der Hochzeit mit Dewa
konvertierte Monica zum Hinduismus.
Die komplizierten Gebetsrituale
sind für sie auch nach zehn Jahren
noch immer eine Herausforderung.
* Meditative Musik *
Je mehr ich verstehe
und von Dewa lerne,
desto wohler fühle ich mich auch.
Es ist so, als habe ich hier unten
Zugang zum Glauben gefunden.
Vorher war mir das nicht wichtig.
Aber ich fühle mich einfach wohl.
* Meditative Musik *
Duduc. Hinsetzen.
Setzt euch hin.
Sie kann sich hierhersetzen
und die Beine strecken.
Sie möchte lieber dorthin.
* Sie sprechen balinesisch. *
Kulturelle
und sprachliche Unterschiede
erschweren den Kontakt zur Familie.
Monica spricht Indonesisch,
kein Balinesisch.
Das führt oft zu Missverständnissen.
Im grösseren Clan der Familie -
und das ist ja meistens der Fall -
gab es schon Widerstände.
Man sagte mir klar und deutlich,
was der Standard ist,
um akzeptiert zu werden.
Und das bedeutet,
richtig gut Balinesisch zu können.
Ich kann
noch immer kein Balinesisch.
* Er spricht balinesisch. *
Mein Papa sagt immer: "Du bist
für dein Glück verantwortlich."
"Wenn du glücklich bist,
bin ich es auch."
Für mich ist es okay.
Sie ist die Liebe meines Lebens.
Ich liebe sie bis in alle Ewigkeit.
So schön. Du bist
auch die Liebe meines Lebens.
Oh, das friert mich.
Wenn die Götter auch finden,
du hättest das Richtige gemacht ...
Also, wenn das Herz spricht ...
- Ja.
Seine Familie bedeutet Dewa viel.
Als Erstgeborener müsste er
traditionellerweise hier wohnen.
Weil das für das Paar schwierig wäre,
unterstützt er seine Angehörigen mit
Geld und lässt das Haus renovieren.
Dieser Durchgang steht falsch.
Der Priester kennt die Regeln.
Ich mache es so, wie er will.
Ich will meine Familie unterstützen.
Ich mache das
mit meinem eigenen Geld,
ich muss
nicht erst meine Frau fragen.
Das ist wichtig.
Dewa, erinnerst du dich?
- Yes.
Das ist zehn Jahre her.
Unsere Hochzeit war superschön.
Ich war so beeindruckt von all
den Opfergaben - ich war sprachlos.
Weil hier nur Paare mit
derselben Konfession heiraten dürfen,
konvertierte Monica.
Das war eine langwierige Zeremonie.
Zuerst hatte ich eine Taufe.
Das ging schon einen Tag.
Es gab verschiedene Stufen,
bis hin zum Zähnefeilen.
Damit stellt man sicher,
dass man den animalischen Trieb
wegfeilen kann.
Die Eckzähne sind das Symbol
für den animalischen Trieb.
So schwächt man den eigentlich ab.
Ich machte fast in die Hosen.
Ich dachte,
alle können meinen Herzschlag hören.
Es war extrem: Als der Typ feilte,
war es
wie eine Bombe in meinem Kopf.
Ich war echt froh, als alles
vorbei war und wir beten konnten.
Ah, die Familien ...
Interessant. Ich war nervös.
Der Vater meiner Frau
sprach kein Englisch.
Ich versuchte, mit meinem Herzen
zu sprechen und lächelte.
Ich bemühte mich sehr
und lächelte pausenlos.
Das hat geholfen. Alles war gut.
Ähnlich wie ich anfangs in Bali -
ich lächelte auch nur.
Nach zweiwöchigen Zeremonien
gaben sich die beiden das Jawort.
Die eigentliche Hochzeit
dauerte drei Tage lang.
Dewa war damals 28,
Monica 48 Jahre alt.
Hier war ich so glücklich.
Der Baiasagung war so schwer.
- Ja.
Ich schwebte vor Glück.
Ich war in dieser Welt,
aber irgendwie auch nicht.
So schön.
Nach der Hochzeit fragten sie dann
immer: "Bist du schon schwanger?"
"Bist du schon schwanger?"
Das war ein immenser Druck.
Da sagte ich Dewa:
"Wir müssen ihnen klar sagen,
dass wir keine Kinder haben werden."
Von da an haben sie es verstanden.
Sie
konnten mich ja nicht rauswerfen.
Es ist nicht unser Fehler.
- So ist es.
Bonjour.
Florence hat heute
ihre Feuertaufe als Assistenzlehrerin
für Französisch.
Setzt euch.
Heute machen wir eine
Übung zum Future proche und Berufen.
Florence hat seit Kurzem
an der internationalen Schule
ein kleines Pensum.
This evening.
Next week.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ihr das seht -
alle haben es richtig gemacht.
Das ist auch,
um Kontakte zu knüpfen.
Für mehr Integration
und um etwas anderes zu machen
und nicht
nur alleine im Wald zu sitzen.
Bitte alles aufräumen.
Unterrichten lenkt Florence von den
Anstrengungen der letzten Monate ab.
Der Hausbau brachte sie und Niklas
an ihre Grenzen.
Du hast deine Energie verloren
und ich meine. Das war hart.
Morgens um 8 Uhr aufstehen,
Überhose anziehen und rausgehen
und abends um 19 Uhr
kaputt reinkommen ...
Dann
kriegte ich noch Schlafstörungen
und hatte die Nase einfach voll.
Ab und zu
setzten wir uns hin und sagten:
"Tief durchatmen,
etwas runterfahren."
Wir machten es gut
in diesem ganzen Chaos.
Dass sich Niklas
nur langsam von der Operation erholt,
führen die beiden
auf diese anstrengende Zeit zurück.
Auch im Gästehaus
geht ihnen die Arbeit nicht aus.
Lange nicht mehr hier gewesen.
Es ist kalt.
Es ist okay, erst mal.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie man das abschliesst.
It's still open.
Aha, das ist alles? Okay.
Ich hänge es hier an den Schrank,
ja?
Was ist es?
- Die Öffnungszeiten der Tierklinik.
Wir haben z.B. auch ...
... eine kleine Notfallapotheke
für die Hunde.
Es hat Sachen für Durchfall ...
Darum haben wir die Öffnungszeiten
hier, falls es doch mal brennt.
So.
Ich habe die Pflanzen
gestern gebadet.
Eigentlich war das Gästehaus
nur für Freunde gedacht,
doch jetzt wollen sie
auch "Ferien mit dem Hund" anbieten.
Der Aufwand für das Gästehaus stieg,
er hat sich fast verdoppelt.
Diese ganzen Materialkosten ...
Das Gästehaus
kostete schliesslich 200'000 Fr.
Unser Haus war 400'000 Fr.
Wir reden hier
von Schweizer Franken.
Das Gästehaus
soll auch eine Investition sein,
nicht nur ein Kostenfaktor.
Wenn etwas Geld reinkäme,
wäre das gut.
Vielleicht kriegen wir es
irgendwann wieder rein.
Am Abend zieht es Niklas und Florence
an ihren Privatstrand am See,
wie so oft.
Siehst du die Risse hier?
Es gibt schon Risse.
Es ist schwierig, hier zu baden.
Du kannst untertauchen, schwimmen -
am selben Ort ...
Ich mache Eistauchen.
Es hat doch noch
ein paar Zentimeter Eis.
Nature girl.
Wenn ich zwischen so was
und einem Fünf-Sterne-Hotel
auf den Malediven wählen kann,
nehme ich das hier.
Versuchen wir es.
Clean it out.
Ich bin hier.
No.
Nein, ich will mich nicht schneiden,
dann haben wir zwei Verletzte.
Der Wille war da.
Siehst du? Ich kann ausrutschen.
Dann kannst du
mich nicht rausziehen.
Es ist tief.
Ich weiss nicht, wie tief.
Wäre die Leiter hier,
wäre es kein Problem.
Man kann sich daran festhalten
und wieder raufkommen.
Aber ich habe gerade gemerkt,
dass ich nur auf dem Eis ausrutsche.
Das ist mir zu heiss.
Das Leben ist wunderbar.
Es ist, was man daraus macht.
Die einen machen es komplizierter,
wie ich.
Ja, eine Frau
mit 235 Hunden zu heiraten.
Ja, aber das hast du gesagt.
Es sind diese kleinen Momente.
Sie kosten nichts
und sind wunderschön.
* Ruhige Musik *
Als ich die Schweiz
wieder etwas kennenlernte,
stellte ich fest, dass viele Leute
sehr unglücklich sind,
weil es hinten und vorne
nicht reicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das der richtige Weg ist.
Man könnte den Luxus runterschrauben
und mehr Lebensqualität haben.
Didi Kunz zog vor zwölf Jahren
auf die Philippinen.
Auch wegen des günstigen Lebens.
Monatlich gebe er 800-1'500 Fr. aus,
sagt er.
Da hat es eine Rechnung.
Das ist mein Briefkasten.
Da ist die Rechnung drin.
Das ist die einzige Rechnung,
die ich hier habe.
Das ist die Stromrechnung.
Die liegt jetzt bei ... 6.50 Fr.
Du kannst keinen finden,
der so ist wie er,
auf den Philippinen.
- Not possible.
Du kannst auch
keinen anderen Schweizer finden,
der gleich ist wie ich.
- Nein.
Im Paradies
fällt einem das Essen in den Mund,
hier fallen Kokosnüsse von der Palme.
Ein Bauer aus der Nachbarschaft
erntet sie.
Ui, die ist kaputt gegangen.
Wir müssen die Kokosnüsse
runterholen, auch wegen der Kinder.
Sie fallen in der Nähe des Hauses.
Das ist gefährlich.
Oppa.
Das Kokoswasser ist ein Genuss.
Auf Didi
hat es eine besondere Wirkung.
That's power.
Das Leben am Meer
regt die Fantasie der Mädchen an
und beide
können sich gut selber beschäftigen.
Das ist eine Meerjungfrau.
Nur eine Meerjungfrau.
Und hier habe ich noch eine Barbie.
Reis ist das Nationalgericht.
Doch heute
kocht Melisa Didis Leibspeise.
Schätzchen, was machst du Leckeres?
- Spaghettisauce.
Love you.
- Hey, come on.
Für mich ist Liebe ein Ganzes.
Es ist nicht nur Geld,
es ist Liebe, Respekt und Vertrauen.
Didi und ich haben
eine gute Beziehung.
Mir genügt ein einfaches Leben,
solange man glücklich ist.
Es ist nicht einfach, das Glück
zu finden mit einer Familie.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Schatzi ...
Das Leben in der Schweiz
mag in vielem komfortabler sein.
Doch Didi und Melisa
würden sich immer wieder
für die Philippinen entscheiden.
Und füreinander.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie oft man das im Leben haben kann.
Es gibt wohl wirkliche Liebe,
die ...
Jetzt glaube ich dran.
Es ist heiss.
* Entspannte Musik *
* Ruhige Musik *
Sein erster Ausgang.
- Er wird doch nicht frieren?
28 Std. nach der Geburt von Noam
dürfen die frischgebackenen
Väter Jamal und Romain
die Klinik verlassen.
Jetzt sind sie eine Familie.
Es ist speziell, den kleinen Knopf
hier draussen zu sehen.
Jetzt wird er die Welt entdecken.
Das ist toll.
Jetzt verlässt er
auch das medizinische Umfeld.
Bisher
war er umgeben von Pflegepersonal.
Jetzt realisiere ich,
dass wir nun komplett
für ihn verantwortlich sind.
Il apprend froid, le petit.
Es ist kalt im Auto.
Gestern Abend haben sie sich
von Leihmutter Ashley verabschiedet.
Sie konnte
schlussendlich vor uns gehen.
Wir wollten Ashley
Noam natürlich vorstellen.
Wir gingen in ihr Zimmer
und sie hielt ihn.
Wir haben ein Foto für Noam gemacht,
damit er das auch mal sehen kann.
Die Fahrt zurück nach Montreal
dauert 6 Std.
Weil es schon spät ist,
verbringen die drei noch
eine Nacht im Hotel in Hamilton.
Er schläft und schläft.
- Das ist sehr gut.
Il faut ... Il faut ...
In 1 Std. müssen wir ihn füttern.
- Ja.
Wie spät ist es?
Jetzt ist es 17.30 Uhr.
18.30 Uhr wäre perfekt
für eine Reservation im Restaurant.
Das wird
sein erster Restaurantbesuch,
sein erstes Hotel -
und er ist erst einen Tag alt.
Will er vielleicht essen, nein?
- Ja.
Vielleicht wickeln wir ihn später?
In 1 Std. isst er.
* Romain macht Babygeräusche. *
* Noam gurgelt. *
Hm? Coucou.
Mon amour.
Riecht er ein wenig nach Pipi?
Nein, das riecht nicht schlecht.
Nach Kräutern.
Peut-être un peu pipi.
Gestern haben wir im Spital gelernt,
wie man ein kleines Kind einpackt,
damit es draussen nicht friert,
dass es entspannt ist
und es bequem hat.
Wir tun unser Bestes.
* Noam schreit. *
Ein mexikanischer Burrito - perfekt.
Gehen wir schlafen? 1 Std. schlafen?
1 Std. schlafen,
dann gibt es wieder zu essen.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Hin und weg":
Ein Anruf verändert das Leben
von Niklas und Florence.
Zwei Monate
nach der Blinddarmoperation
riefen sie mich an und sagten,
es sehe nicht gut aus.
Ich habe Krebs.
Die Welt stand Kopf.
Da gab es ein paar Tage,
an denen ich 24 Std. nur weinte.
(Didi) Erinnerst du dich
an die Schule hier?- Oh Gott.
Auf den Philippinen melden sich
die Mädchen in ihrer alten Schule an.
Ich möchte ihnen
ein gutes Leben ermöglichen.
Wir achten darauf,
dass sie genügend lernen.
* Noam schreit. *
In Montreal hält Noam alle auf Trab.
Momentan geht einfach der,
der zuerst aufwacht.
Jetzt geht es gut.
Aber wenn ich wieder arbeite,
wird es sehr hart.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023